Why do we launch rockets in Florida?
I rememberas a kid just not getting it as I watched these rocket launches get scrubbed
due to bad weather.
I was like, you guys know that's Florida right?
that's where they get the hurricanes and the
thunderstorms .
and you know one of the Apollo missions got hit by a lightning strike on its wayout of the atmosphere
it's unbelievable
but there are two very good reasons why they launch rockets from here.
the first is because the ground beneath our feet is moving to the East veryfast
Everything is going about 900 miles per hour
that's 1500 kilometers per hour
and that means as
your rocket takes off up and to the east
it starts off with that velocity.
The Earth is giving that
rocket an initial boost so you don't have to put
in as much energy. You don't have to speed it up asmuch.
Now the other thing is if you're gonna fly to the East and something goes wrong with that rocket
you're going to want it to not hurt anything
what's nice about Florida is what you have overthere is ocean
not the rest of your country.